buvez et rester jeune la révolution anti
âge protège votre pouls du
vieillissement et des rides
quel est ce produit miracle le cocktail
vitalité d'inova q c'est une gelée qu'on
ajoute à un liquide mais la pub
lentilles pas plus est ce un médicament
un produit naturel non c'est un aliment
le tableau des valeurs nutritives
d'ailleurs imprimé sur la boîte comme
pour la plupart des aliments et que
contient cette potion anti-âge des
fibres et les vitamines à c et e
elle contient aussi quand la gère selon
les nutritionnistes que nous avons
consulté les aliments que vous consommez
contiennent déjà tout ça sent les sucres
ajoutés et les arômes artificiels
ensuite rien ne garantit que collagène
de ce produit se fixera dans votre peau
pour la gare des jeunes bref à 55 $ plus
taxes aux deux semaines
tout ce que ce produit va révolutionner
c'est votre budget